this is a just stop o protester being
arrested and this is me at a pro
Palestine protest in brickton where two
kids under the age of 18 were arrested
for what they had written on their sign
two people that got arrested this
weekend I took to the Streets of London
to show you from the inside what is
happening at these protests in our
Capital so if you want to know what was
written on those placards how the
mainstream media covering both Pro
Palestine and Rising just op PA protest
then stick around as we head into the
chaotic Streets of London talking to
those involved so we're here at New
Scotland Yard because before we go to
the pro Palestine protest we thought
we'd check out just stop oil it's cop 28
happening and they have a protest here a
little bit underwhelming I'm not going
to lie cuz there's about 50 people but
we have been told by the police that
some of them may well be in breach of
their bail conditions so they could get
arrested however it's a very British
protest so basically what they've said
is these people may slowly walk into the
road at which point the police will
slowly follow them and slowly arrest
them so not much action happening at the
moment clearly not enough people believe
that not ever using oil again is the
right solution to the world's problems
three NOS we're not aiming for the Tiani
arrest okay and I believe we have some
lovely speeches from some lovely young
people so if they want to start coming
up so I can get off
stage where they
G oblique intent is where you don't
specifically want want to kill people by
extremes of drought heat and flood but
you know with certainty that your
policies are contributing to mass death
and suffering we have a corrupt criminal
justice system and that is determined to
play its part in crushing the
[Music]
young I don't know who I'm passing
to sorry
guys
I don't know what to do
with we'll be off in about 2 minutes
great content thank you
remember so we're about to set off I
think I think there's going to be a slow
March through the road at which point I
think some of them might get arrested
we'll find out anyone gets a muffin
they're not vegan I'm afraid cuz I swipe
them from holiday
I'm not joking muffin Apple it's
important to say help yourself no
worries who is Ella and what was she
arrested for she was arrested for
walking in the
road stopping traffic oh she was
arrested for campaigning against this
government's illegal policies which ones
the the complete ignorance of the uh the
huge uh uh risk to the the existential
risk to the human race how much would it
cost to get us carbon
neutral um I don't have that in my head
at the moment okay uh well I can tell
you what though how okay it will be a
lot cheaper than the collapse of the
environment which is imminent just look
around you the world's on
fire and we've known about this is it
well not in this country but just go and
look at what's happening in the in the
tropics just look at the amount of
wildfires that have broken out all over
the country all over the world this this
year just look at the the the the rate
at which the economy the uh global
economy is collapsing just look at the
the rate of
change what is the rate at which the
global economy is collapsing sorry I
must have missed this well I'm sure you
can find that out you're a reporter
after all you before you have your
sources
DET you know you're on the wrong side of
and the murder of the Palestinian people
at the hands of Zionist most
Jews Jewish people
have by colonists the police have
arrested someone and he hasn't even
broken any laws he hasn't even stepped
onto the road yet so why have they
arrested him do you think because well I
mean you should ask them yeah well I did
but the police never talked to anyone
with camera they don't right I mean you
can understand why I suppose cuz they've
got superiors telling them not to is it
because this person's breached their
bail conditions maybe cuz that's what we
were told by the police I don't know to
be honest I don't know what his bail
conditions are but it would be
astonishing to me if his Bell conditions
were don't stand on the side of the
[Applause]
pavement
OT so someone has being dragged off and
into a police
van and everyone else is applauding it
which is
odd whatever you think about it it's
quite heavy policing if you compare it
to some of the things that were
happening in some other protests in
recent weeks they're really Keen to
crack down on it we're full of peace and
love if you're enjoying this video make
sure to hit subscribe now and also
comment below to let me know what other
protest across Europe you'd like us to
check out also make sure you stick
around to the end to hear my take on the
day
Alex
don't guys do you know why your friend
was arrested he was on the pavement and
the police came up and arrested him and
I think that's disgusting it is uh a
breach of our human rights to protest I
mean just look how many police fans
there are here right now I mean it's
just it's absolutely diabolical they
should be prosecuting um the real
criminals people like gishy sunak who
are allowing this to happen who are
allowing the climate crisis to worsen I
mean I have to say there is a hell of a
lot of police here for what is
objectively a nonviolent not
particularly scary protest but the
people but the people are stronger
stronger than they are than they are
repression we've lost one person lost we
lost three people we've lost three
people we find ourselves in a position
where we we want to have a March we want
to March along the road with a big group
of people and it's been prea with the
police and at this point in history you
cannot do that it's illegal to do that
we've been we've had a section seven
imposed on us the police have said we
can continue on the pavement but we
cannot march on the road shame on the
police shame on thece shame on the
government shame on the government
talking to these just St World
protesters really shows you that these
are by and large very well-meaning
people but as you've seen not very
organized they don't really seem to know
exactly what they want I don't think
they've considered the tradeoffs of the
policies that they're advocating so it
does seem that these are really just
stop the world I want to get off that
protest I'll be your facilitator woo um
why are we
here why are we here why are we
here justice justice okay what do we
want justi when do we want
it the rest on the pavement that's the
only place we're allowed to protest is
on the pavement we know that this is not
what protest looks like we didn't even
get to step in the road before they
forced us off they picked off two of us
they put three of us in Vans and we
never even stepped onto the road this is
what oppression looks like this is what
it looks like when people don't have the
right to
protest so we are walking slowly towards
Westminster uh in front of the just stop
all protesters watch out we're walking
on the pavement because a couple of
people I think tried to go into the road
they immediately got arrested this is
what's
happening someone's not getting the
message defending the future of
ourselves and millions and billions of
people around the planet is punishable
by sentences of
months in in prison like actual prison
free Markus fre
free k fre K free Ella free we stand in
solidarity with
you when London's underwater when
London's underwater you listen then
you'll just stop oil when London's
underw when London's under water you'll
listen then you'll just stop all
o
I'll get arrested for crap
drumming there's a bit of drumming which
is exciting you know this might come
playing last week without drumming and
chanting it's just not as good fre
[Music]
Kiara
just stop oil just stop
oil why if we ask you a couple of
questions okay no worries I want to talk
to somebody but not everyone wants to
talk to
[Music]
Mees why are you here yes I'm here
because I'm quite concerned about the
climate crisis in July 2022 we had got
40° heat in this country also around the
world um 2023 is very certain to be the
hottest year ever and that is only going
to become worse if we continue to burn
oil and gas we still got so You' like us
to stop all oil and gas completely uh
yes all new licenses obviously we still
have got some reserves uh there which we
can use over the next couple of years
but we do need to make efforts to ramp
up renewable energy and use less energy
by having better public transport um
making our homes more energy efficient
and how much will it cost uh well it
will save us money in the long run how
much does it cost to um save all the
people from extreme weather caused uh by
the climate
[Music]
crisis the fascist decisions that this
system and the government and their
complicity in the in the complete
destruction of our future we will not
let that go unnoticed and we will not be
silent about
[Applause]
it you were talking about what the
government is doing you said they were
fascist what do you mean exactly I mean
the I mean there the repression you can
see exactly here for example we can't
march on the road we march on the
pavement only um it's before we even
manag to set foot on the road we were
there were three arrests I mean we're
here to March against Injustice and
before we could even start the March
people are being arrested it kind of
sums it up right there right do you
think that they're arresting people
because they don't want you to block the
traffic wouldn't that be why they're
doing it that would be I mean I think
the real question is why don't the
government want to secure a livable
future why don't they want to listen to
the science the 6,600 peer-reviewed ipcc
scientists that's a that's a un
sanctioned report that states that new
oil and gas is comp incompatible with a
livable future I think the real question
is why doesn't the people in that
building and why don't the people in
that building jail the real criminals
instead of imprisoning 18-year-olds for
trying to protest because they're
terrified about their future and when
you say the real criminals who are you
referring to rishy sunak and shell CEO
rishy sunak you'd like the police to
arrest the Prime Minister we we have we
have uh given a dossier of evidence to
Mark Roland the head of the Met police
stating exactly how rishy sunx actions
amount to crimes against humanity um I'm
sure you would agree that Hitler should
have been arrested during his Peak I
would yeah exactly so it's it's not do
you think rishy sunak is Hitler I think
rishy sunak is amounting to crimes
against humanity okay thanks for your
time really appreciate it the protest is
moving on as you can see some thoughts
about the media and all of this and
perhaps we'll we'll we'll talk about
this more later but this was a tiny
protest there was almost nobody there
why
oh it was covered by probably as many
journalists secondly as you can see
right now there was a ton of police
for about 50 protesters there was
probably more police than protesters
here again they're obviously making sure
these people don't get into the roads
but even so I think one of the things it
demonstrates is the police can crack
down on protests and prevent things from
getting out of hand and prevent the laws
from being broken if there's enough of
them and if there's the political will
to do it and that probably means that
the resources won't being used somewhere
else like stopping crime policing other
protests Etc so follow us as we head
over to a pro Palestine protest and see
what's happening there we'll find out if
there's enough police and what they're
getting up to we have arrived at in
brickton at um Windrush square there's a
protest happening and the police have
just arrived I don't know where they're
going to do we're about to find out
there's a lot of protesters here someone
here says hoot for Gaza why you here sir
there why are you here sir we've been
doing this for a few weeks now yes if
you go out into the middle of the
traffic people start hooting straight
away okay inant SP especially Sunday
afternoon at Hearn Hill you can get them
hooting for a minute nonstop is that cuz
they they're trying to get home no
that's cuz we stay H for Gaza they for
Gaza I see I
see
so it looks like the police are
basically keeping him off the road
that's basically it's all is happening
here what brings you here to the protest
um I've just come here to show
solidarity with the Palestinian people
because they're having such a terrible
time in Gaza and they're being
slaughtered and their children are being
slaughtered and their homes are being
destroyed and things could be different
that part of the world could be living
in in peace and democracy and instead
we're having this bloody Great War and I
came here to show solidarity and now I
find that the police around here are
starting trouble by arresting young
people with PLU cards what are they
arresting them for they've they've
arrested one young person they've
arrested in there and he's been there
since I got here which is about nearly
an hour and um and they won't let him go
and he's got something written on his
pla card which says okay it says
Zionism is like narcissism something
like that I that's the secondhand
comment I didn't see it somebody told me
that's what he'd written and you
mentioned you think that you don't
arrest people for that you don't arrest
people that you might argue with them
you might say are you sure that's true
he's a young person he's maybe made a
mistake but honestly this is not good
policing I've seen good policing on all
the other demonstrations I've been on to
support Palestine I've seen good
policing this is terrible they've
stirred up a riot maybe that's what they
wanted you said that part of the the
world would be living in peace and
democracy could be what would need to
happen for that to happen uh if we if we
didn't have a state a racist state in
Israel if Israel was run as a totally
equal democracy and all Palestinians and
all the other all the people in that
part of the world could live under an
equal rights government then we wouldn't
have this situation the police have now
blocked off the road as well uh one
person's been apparently arrested and
we'll find out more about what's going
on
here
[Music]
let let go let
go there
[Music]
many people are being l mured right now
babies parents families wiped out two
people that got arrested for standing up
for what's
right free
[Applause]
[Music]
free sh
on shame on you sh
the longer it goes on the more important
I think it is for people to show support
cuz numbers drop off the way that it's
being handled by people in power does
need challenging and clearly there's
like who do you mean when you say people
in power I mean the governments and I
mean of which country this country this
country like there's it's it's too hard
to sum up briefly like and what would
you like to see happen now change like
first of all the ceasefire that
primarily save lives and then a
two-state solution I guess probably two
State solution yeah I came here today
because I'm concerned about the
terrorism off the Israeli State okay in
invading Gaza and uh 198 people have
been killed since the ceasefire has
ended uh innocent unarmed uh
Palestinians and more or less to call
for a ceasefire a permanent ceasefire
what do you say to people who say there
was a ceasefire before October 7th and
this is why there's the fighting
now yeah well sometimes ceas fires break
down uh uh I was involved myself uh when
the first Irish ceasefire broke down uh
in um January
1975 I was involved myself in talks
between the IRA and the and the British
government in order to get the ceasefire
resumed wow I'm chairman of the Irish
Civil Rights Association I had stood for
Parliament here in October 1974 I led
seven candidates for the Irish Civil
Rights Association and because I had
taken part in the Democratic process I
was able to make a phone call to the IRA
and to the British government and I just
simply asked them would the
representative of each of the meet with
a A View to get in the ceasefire resume
I want a ceasefire and I want the
lifting of s of The Siege now there are
many many thousands of people living in
very very small area they have got no
army they have got no Navy they have got
no Air Force now they have hardly any
health care at all because it's been
bombed to
smithin and they are like fish in a gold
fish bowl being shot at and how do you
think we get peace now we get peace by
the United Nations which is the only
organization that is worldwide pulling
together all the Arab Nations around
there who are excuse my language halfway
up the US
ass to come out of that to have a the
sort of sympathy that I have got for the
human life that is being destroyed in
front of our eyes before the attack on
October 7th on Israel in which 1200
civilians were killed there people would
argue that was a ceasefire that was
broken by Hamas what would you say to
those people well I would say to those
people that Gaza was still under siege
it was still the people of Gaza were
completely controlled by the Israeli
government as we've seen because as soon
as it happened the water was cut off
food was cut off everything was cut off
they were only allowed at that time so
many calories a day
controlled by the Israelis while we were
talking to this lovely lady sort of
calmed down a bit the road has been
opened up crowds mostly chilled out as
well it just seems to have become mostly
peaceful M can I ask you a couple of
questions to find out what's going on
here uh sure quickly who are you from
first uh we're an independent YouTube
channel we go to protest and film
documentaries about it independ okay
yeah okay I take your suspicious of
mainstream TV or oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
I I call it rightwing TV Man rightwing
TV n they'll cut and edit any and
everything you say and just like try to
paint a bad picture of you okay and if
you keep everything clean then they just
won't AAR it anyway so which channels
are you talking about uh let's say on
freev viiew all of them except for Al
jazer and above Al jazer GB news and
talk TV they're even more right-wing and
say like the BBC and the Zionist Sky
News for example you think Sky News is
rightwing and Zionist and BBC definitely
uh 14-year-old had a sign that they
didn't quite like the sign said
ceasefire now children are not
collateral damage and then a very small
rting had said stop Zion naism but
because the word Z Nai was in there they
didn't like the sign so they grabbed the
14-year-old we had a bit of a standoff
and this gentleman and I helped calm
things down on our respective sides and
what would you like to see happen now
with the conflict uh then just stop the
air strikes on civilians stop talking in
civilian homes water storage solar
panels un schools where civilians are
taking shelter stop with the air strikes
on civilians if they really want a war
fight it out in the streets of Gaza City
where they're being hunted by alasan
brigades we're destroying hundreds of
their tanks and killing thousands of
their troops fight a real war on the
ground which they can't win if you were
in charge of Israel on October 8th what
would you do uh well you have to do a
little investigation you know what I
mean you can't just automatically look
to bomb Gaza into Oblivion you got a
hostage CR guess what you might kill
some of your hostages which is exactly
what they've done they've killed scores
of them so you see October 7th is them
breaking out against the the occupation
resistance yeah yeah resistance been a
long time coming retaliation to many
previous massacres in the Gaza Strip
they hit every single military base
around Gaza within 6 minutes this is not
self-defense you know this this is not
war this this is I think think they want
to kill them all it's it's a genocide
they it's an extermination of the whole
people of Gaza and why do you say they
want to kill them all I'm I think the
evidence is there they I think they've
already flattened about 60% of the
buildings I think the numbers are about
15,000 now I'm I'm certain that's a
conservative estimate but the majority
of the hospitals have been destroyed
they're not functioning they're
attacking schools I don't see how gazin
can survive unless there's an immediate
ceasefire if I'm a victim of any kind of
assault that doesn't exempt me from the
moral order now the Israelis as I
understand that they regard the IDF as
the most moral army in the world I mean
that's a sick joke now because they seem
to think that uh the fact that they were
victims of this assault it it um exempts
them from the moral order well that's
not the case so whatever response you
make you have to do so within I'm a
Catholic there's a a just War Theory
which is about using legitimate force
and not harming civilians and so on that
applies to everybody you feel that
they're not respecting that certainly
not I'm a trauma National expert in um
in the UK and I think one thing that is
important is that actually trauma the
mechanism of trauma in the brain silence
people silence the voice of people
genocide is what is happening and in
some ways I think the Western countries
are silencing not just the trauma that
we observing and absorbing but but also
the the the governments are doing that
as a doctor as a physician is very hard
actually to be in the position of
feeling you need to help people when
they come to your unit and they
traumatize but at the same time what are
we doing with this kind of um colluding
in our governments to a major crime that
is traumatizing further human beings
talking to a lot of people about October
7th as well I'm I'm guessing the way
Israel is responding seems to be a
response to the trauma that they
suffered as well you know I'm a bit
cynical about that every human being is
been traumatized one way or another and
I don't think you can excuse your
behavior on trauma that you've been
suffering inflicting it to others we are
wrapping up here we came to Brixton uh
to catch a pro Palestine protest it was
very interesting at the beginning this
road here was completely blocked off by
the police who were trying to push the
protesters back onto the pavement
eventually they succeeded again as with
other protests we've covered difficult
to get uh a kind of answer about how
people think we should move forward but
yeah an interesting day all around we
are driving home after a long day of
documenting the various protests very
similar numbers of people are both
protest but they were policed very
differently the just op oil one had
overwhelming numbers of officers it
could be because it was in Westminster I
don't know it could be because they're
really cranking down on those particular
protesters and it was interesting you
know because we in in this particular
situation we didn't see any of the
hateful or sort of violent rhetoric that
we've seen on uh other protests at least
on social media and stuff and talking to
people you know I didn't get the sense
that there were many people there
because they really were anti-semitic or
hated Jews or even necessarily hated
Israel I think there may have been one
or two but generally speaking I just
think it was people who were empathetic
to the plight of people in Gaza the
thing that I really took away from it
for me was that it was quite a lot of
people who they don't see the whole
picture but they are empathetic and
caring people so when they see people
being killed and people being being
injured by bombs they feel compassion
there but that was my takeaway the thing
that I really saw was people who you
know the moment you start to ask them
well what would you have done if you
were in charge of Israel after October
7th Etc they they don't really have an
answer it's a very complicated situation
obviously we are doing meta media
because we're actually covering the way
the media covers that issue which I I
thought was fascinating because there
was so many photographers there there
was so much other media there
at the just and there was a ton of
police there uh in a way that they just
wasn't at this Pro Palestine protest
even though there was more people
protesting at the pro Palestine protest
than there had been at the just o oil I
didn't encounter any real media other
than like you know independent YouTubers
and stuff of the March against
anti-Semitism I know a lot of you
commented that you're really enjoying
the stuff that we've been filming on the
street of protest Etc we're going to be
doing a lot more of that so make sure
you smash that subscribe button smash
the like button click the Bell as well
so you get notified when new content
comes out and let us know in the
comments what you think are you enjoying
these videos are you enjoying some of
the other stuff that we are doing let us
know that way we're going to be informed
and it shapes what we do with the
channel going
forward